(soft music)
- I don't know how many
other Jefferson lecturers
(audience laughs)
put on their Revolutionary War hat,
but I will deliver part of
the lecture with my hat on.
So I'm gonna talk about three things,
and they will get increasingly speculative
as we move along, so
I'll give you some facts
about the inequality and globalization
and the ways that I think
they challenge our democracy,
and then, the most speculative part
will be how we're gonna
meet these challenges,
or how we can meet them.
And there is Hamilton, actually,
on the $10 bill, and I
thought about putting
Jefferson, he's on the two dollar bill,
and he's also on the nickel.
This is basically the
theme I wanna go through.
The threat we see from
inequality is that wealthy people
can use money to protect their money,
and that was a deep concern
of Mr. Jefferson, indeed,
and then, globalization, the concern is,
it doesn't matter what the state does,
the state can't tax as much,
'cause capital is very mobile,
so it can't redistribute income
from the upper income groups
to the lower income groups,
and those are the two principle specters,
that inequality weakens the democracy,
and then even when the government
might wanna do something,
the globalization says, No, you can't.
And then, the word feudalistic is more
of a word used in Jefferson's time,
when we think about multi-nationals
and super wealthy folks making decisions,
and then I had to add in to this quote,
the potential villains in this piece
are people like many of the academics
and people at Berkeley, and myself.
It's people who go around the globe
and are not particularly
tied to the country
in which they live,
academics are prone to this,
and so are a lot of multi-national firms.
And I know my university
does not consider itself
an American university, we
are a global university,
just the way IBM does not
consider itself an American firm.
And the question is how this
can also weaken the things.
So these are some things just to show you
the historic and the Jefferson
and we have Hamilton,
and the word here,
aristocracy is not a word
we use particularly nowadays to refer
to things but Jefferson's concern,
"The aristocracy of our
moneyed corporations."
De Tocqueville was also worried
that we would create this
permanent inequality and aristocracy.
Interestingly, Jefferson
was for free trade,
so on the globalization debate,
he would've been for globalization,
but that was because the fear was
that tariffs and other
protections from trade
were gonna strengthen
the moneyed corporations.
The farmers were not moneyed corporations,
they were just the individuals working.
And Hamilton also, and that reflects
the Hamilton Project that
the Brookings Institution,
which I'll say more about,
'cause I really saw that
as very interesting at
a Jefferson lecture.
But it was not just more
aristocratic things,
it was more expert decisions,
and we now have that,
in large part, the Federal
Reserve will make some decisions
today and tomorrow,
unelected set of people,
experts, I personally have great faith
in that Ben Bernanke will do good things
and will try to make the best decisions,
but nonetheless, it's very interesting
that a lot of how the economy will operate
over the next, at least short term period,
will depend upon experts, you
could call them aristocratic,
but folks who were certainly not elected
by anybody in our country,
and then John Jay,
who was part of the
Hamilton gang, or group,
people who own the country
ought to govern it.
That is not very helpful to democracy,
so we'll now see the double specters.
So this, I'll go very
quickly over the inequality,
because I think there's
just widespread agreement
and there can be no arguments about this.
I started off with all the good things
the US economy's done, and
we've been very successful
in many ways, and we had excellent growth
of GDP per capita over the
last, it's 16 years here.
And then the skeleton is
our distribution of income.
We have got an extraordinary
unequal distribution.
So let me give you some figures here,
just so you see the nature of it.
The figure to the left
is, that's a 90/10 ratio,
that's at the bottom, and at
the top is a GINI coefficient.
90/10 ratio takes the wages of the people
in the 90th percentile and
divides it by the wages
of people in the 10th percentile.
It's a measure of labor market.
GINI coefficient is for the
overall income distribution.
The dots are different
countries, advanced countries.
So Japan, Canada, Britain, Germany,
and we're out there, obviously,
number one in both of those metrics.
The straight lines, the
bar graphs to the right,
are to me the most remarkable indication
of how unequal our country is.
The first one is a standard
deviation of log earnings,
which is an indicator, which
is a measure of earnings.
Inequality, so higher
numbers are more unequal.
So that's a 0.88, that's all Americans.
Then you'd go and you'd take Americans
who have the same score
on a global literacy test,
which was done by the
OECD, was done in a lot
of the, a number of advanced countries.
And so those are people
with similar abilities,
at least measured by a literacy score.
And you can narrow that further,
you can do it by similar ability,
exactly the same gender,
pretty much the same age,
you could even look
within broad occupations,
and you basically will get
similar results to this.
Anybody at Labor Conference who worked
with earnings distributions, you know
that you put in all the controls you want
and you're left with a lot of variability.
And I like thinking about that as,
you have students in
exactly the same class,
all scoring reasonably well on an exam,
and look at them 10 years later.
You will see, again, the same degree
and the same university, I'm
thinking of my own students
in the 10 year class of
economics at Harvard.
And when they graduate
and go 10 years later,
you'll have the investment
banker making huge sums,
you'll have the graduate student
not making huge sums, as we know,
and you'll have a just
incredible dispersion.
Then, because of this dataset,
we were able to get figures
for Germany, all workers,
Netherlands and Sweden,
and the stunning thing
is the inequality in the US of people
with the same scores, and I say,
you could break that down more,
exceeds the inequality in earnings
in those three European
countries of everybody.
That's people who can't read
and people who can read.
People in good jobs
and people in bad jobs.
That's just indication, yeah,
we're really far out in this inequality.
Then I have some figures
from the CIA World Factbook.
There are other figures I could've chosen,
but I chose that one because I thought
some of my conservative
friends might be very critical,
and I would say, well,
it's from the CIA, guys,
so what do you expect?
So there is the GINI coefficients,
and you know, higher GINI
coefficient is more inequality,
so India was lower than
I would've expected,
and maybe the figures are
not so accurate, 0.33,
China is 0.44, the US is 0.45.
US and China have basically
the same inequality of income.
In the 118 countries for
which the World Factbook
gave data, the US was 84th.
So that's not, that's 84th, is
meaning very low in equality.
We're very unequal, yeah.
And the bottom half of
developing countries.
I was stunned at that as
well, but this is all just,
this is that we have a
serious inequality problem
or issue or facts, at least.
We've also seen, over the last 30 years,
and 30 years, meaning it's been
through Republican administrations,
it's been through
Democratic administrations,
it's not a partisan kind of fact.
The facts aren't partisan, in any case.
And the blue line with the dots
is the growth of, is the
level of real hourly earnings
from the series that's the longest
and the most extensive that we had.
The top line with the little triangles,
that's productivity growth.
Productivity growth, and
it's all centered around,
19, I think, 70 was the year I picked,
for just locking it as 100,
and then it just grows.
You see it just spanning out,
and you see the productivity
growth has been very good,
and real wage growth is not.
The intermediate lines
are different measures
of different real wage serieses.
So there's a number of different series
that one can look at, some include
non-wage compensation such
as pensions and healthcare,
et cetera, but whichever one you pick,
it's clearly that productivity growth
has been very good and
none of the real wages
of American workers
have gone up that much.
So we've had a rising,
this obviously produces rising inequality.
Well, productivity growth
has helped some people,
and hopefully these gentlemen
will contribute money to our
university, our universities,
and we'll have a naming
ceremony for this room
or something, and I don't know how much
they would change this
from the Jefferson Lecture
to the Big Bucks Lecture if Mr. Big Bucks
would give the money, but it's clear
these people have done extremely well,
these very wealthy people.
So I wanna give you some extreme views
of the American income distribution.
And the perfect payday, CIOs reap millions
by landing stock options
when they are most valuable.
Luck, or something else?
Great CEO Pay Heist, you can read them.
And then the one that I was stunned at
when I saw, in late September 2001,
right after the World Trade
Center and Pentagon attacks,
I didn't realize scores
of companies ladled out
options to executives worth millions.
So they immediately said,
the stock market falls,
we know it's gonna bounce back
because right now people are in a panic,
so what do we do, the first thing we do
is we give options to ourselves
dated now that the stock
market is way down.
So this particular gentleman calls it
sleazeballs and profiteering ghouls,
is that what business is about?
And then the last one is another,
these are very radical statements.
I would regard these as
incredibly extreme statements.
Where are they from?
You might've been guessing, Jones?
It's the Wall Street
Journal, Fortune magazine,
the story that had not really,
far as I know, gotten very much attention
was these executives writing these options
for themselves right after the attack,
that was the editor of the
Harvard Business Review,
and this was on a PBS broadcast.
And then Forbes magazine.
So this is reading of,
prior to what's happened
in the inequality in the country,
from, you can't get more conservative
than these four organizations,
you know, and conservative
and honest and reputable
and so on, you know, Forbes,
Fortune, Wall Street Journal,
exclusive of the editorial page
is a pretty accurate place,
and the Harvard Business
Review, that's pretty accurate.
So that's some striking, if I say,
I don't think there can be any argument
about what's happened to
the income distribution
in the country and that
something is awry with this.
And then there's another
radical commentary,
and this is from Warren Buffett.
You may have noticed that he's been making
a number of comments since he's given away
his 40 billion dollars or so
to the Bill Gates Foundation,
or 30 billion, and this
was a statement though,
he made to his shareholders,
in which, the best line in this
is the one right towards the end,
"If class warfare is
being waged in America,
"my class is clearly winning."
And then he goes on and points out
that he paid a lower tax
than his receptionist,
and of course, what's going on there
is it's Social Security,
which is top coded,
so you stopped at the
top, and she's paying that
and he's not, on the margin,
so his marginal tax rate
is actually lower than
hers, and he's quite upset
about this, so I think
if we got all these,
the Wall Street Journal, and the Forbes,
and the Harvard Business Review,
and we have one of the country's second,
he was till he gave away all his money,
a lot of his money, the country's
second wealthiest person.
You don't have to be very radical
to say this is a problem.
Okay, so that's my first fact.
And then, what I wanna
do, in the lectures is go,
we take that as given, if
you want more evidence,
there's multiple people,
including many economists
at Berkeley have studied,
we can just give you that evidence.
And then we wanna, later we'll wanna know
and say, what does that
mean for our democracy?
It's happened, it's here, we
have a very unequal society.
Now, the globalization.
And so, these are made up quotes.
I didn't search the web
to find business people
saying this, but certainly,
they say this all the time.
You can find this very easily.
And I'd said the devil made me do it,
but what we say is, it's
the market made me do it.
Globalization made me do it.
And the reason is, we got
cheap labor over there,
we can move and how
could I stay in business
if my competitor moves to
hire the cheaper labor?
And that's a big and
giant issue, a threat.
The globalization, we'll
give couple of facts
about the globalization, so
we understand where that is.
What we have had in the
1990s and the 2000s,
is basically, post the whole
NAFTA discussion and debate,
is a huge increase, I called
it the Great Doubling,
because the global workforce
basically doubled in size
when China and India and
the ex-Soviet joined us.
When China was behind the iron curtain,
the ex-Soviet were
behind the iron curtain,
and India still had made its
own curtain around itself
and didn't really deal
in the global world,
that meant that basically
1.5 billion workers
were out of the global capitalist system,
and so, and there were about 1.5 million
in the global capitalist system,
and so the doubling is just about right.
What happens, any economist will tell you,
if you increase the labor
force by twice as much,
and don't increase the
capital stock by that much,
you are going to have
a shift in market power
towards capital, and I
just phrased it here as
it's more difficult for
market forces to help workers.
Now those, I'm thinking now of workers
in the already advanced
or the capital war world, in our world.
Obviously, this is extraordinarily good
for the Chinese and the Indians,
and it would be great for the ex-Soviets,
if they, even, they get their
act together reasonably,
and I know that's, they've
had more troubles I think,
but the ones, the countries
that have joined the EU,
certainly, are gonna be
doing very very well in the,
Poland, for instance, was
one of the larger ones,
is doing very very well.
So we have this globalization,
which suddenly, it's
not just globalization,
it's globalization with
people who have much lower
capital labor ratios than we have.
And we have global capital flow,
so it just moves overseas.
And then, I think it's more important
what's going on in our sector, actually,
or as important, is
many of these countries,
and particularly China, but India as well,
and Brazil, and you just
go down the country list
and you see this, they've
made large investments
in university education.
So we see many graduate students
from foreign countries
here, a big reason for that
is that there're many
many more undergraduates
in foreign countries than
there were 20 years ago.
So if we thought that
bringing these countries
into our, the same
global, capitalist world
was gonna mean that they did all the,
those guys do all the low level work,
they make the shoes, and we
do all the educated work,
which was the promise, you may remember,
of the NAFTA debate.
NAFTA was, we get to get
all the education stuff,
we're gonna shift over the
bad jobs to the Mexicans.
Well, nobody bothered to ask the Mexicans,
who also increased their
education system a lot.
The Indians, or the Chinese
who are sitting there saying hmm.
Higher education seems
to be really important
in modern economic life, here
are these multi-nationals,
you can get a job with IBM, with Cisco,
whatever it is, get your skills.
So they've made a huge
investment in higher education,
and the multi-nationals are
spreading modern technology.
If you go back to the 50s and 60s,
the vision of globalization would've been,
we have a monopoly of modern technology,
those other guys are using old old stuff,
and our workers,
therefore, have a big edge.
We have a big edge in capital,
and we have a big edge in technology.
And that, both are going away,
and so we see the results.
Lotta trade, offshore and the
immigration tech transfers,
not of the kind that they promised us
during the NAFTA debate.
That's just fact, I think,
and people worry about this.
Now, I put unless we screw up,
I tend to be very favorable
to the globalization.
I think we got about 40, 50 years,
in which these countries
have gotta come up quickly
and grow rapidly and their wages go up,
and it's a transition to
where they are gonna be
comparable to us in their education,
in their use of technology, and so on,
and I think everybody, for the sake
of the vast bulk of humanity,
everybody should have access
to modern technology,
everybody should have
capitalist market economies,
because that's what works and
the other things don't work,
and they should all
have advanced education.
But if they're all gonna get that,
it's gonna be, they're
starting from very low wages,
these places, it's gonna be an interesting
and difficult transition, I
think it's a transition process.
And I say it through trade
and all these things.
What has happened, and interestingly,
is global economic
inequality has declined.
It's declined fairly substantially
since the 19, basically 1990.
Since these countries have
joined the modern world,
if I can phrase it that way.
Basically, it's because China and India
have had such rapid
growth rates, nine, 10%,
well, for China and India, six, 7%.
The very poorest people in the world,
and the people in China and India
had lower incomes per head
than the people in Africa,
on average, and than the
Latin Americans, certainly.
So they moved up, the
very bottom moved up.
At the same time, within every country,
I exaggerate, within most countries,
just like the chart, and
the chart's more accurate
than I am, inequality has gone up.
And I want to point out that's
not strictly globalization,
that's not the only cause,
lotsa things going on.
I mentioned the change in
unionization has gotten weaker.
But during the period of globalization,
within country, inequality has risen.
It's rose in the US, it's risen in China.
It's just been rising over
the last five, six years,
very sharply, in Germany.
It had risen in England earlier.
It's just across the world we see that,
which is an interesting phenomenon
if you start thinking about
the political aspect of this.
The world is getting less unequal
because the poorest people are coming up,
but within every country,
including those countries,
inequality is getting bigger,
and that creates, I
think, interesting issues.
Now, I wanna point out, there's one thing
that didn't come out on this slide.
The telephone call
there, wherever that is.
It's a change, it means change, different.
On my computer it came out
as a little Greek delta.
The US, and it could
just, that's just the US.
We could pick Australia, Canada,
Britain, all the advanced countries,
but we try to focus on the US.
We grew greatly during this period,
so between 1990 and 2006, I show you,
our GDP per capita, in
purchasing power parity
is 1.9%, China grew at 8.9%.
So he says to me, "Oh my god,
China's really doing better."
But then I show you the
absolute dollar amount
of what that growth amounted to,
and we actually had, basically
twice as rapid of growth
in real GDP per capita as China.
And the reason, of course, for that is
that China had such a low level of income
at the beginning that even though
they're growing much more rapidly than us,
that actually added less
real income to China.
So, we had a lot of income
that we could distribute.
Had we distributed the GDP per capita
over this period evenly,
everybody's income gone up
a percentage thing, or
if we had done it evenly,
excuse me, just in lump sums to people,
we could've given every family $11,300.
That's what we bid, and the question was,
how do we distribute it,
and we've already seen,
we did not distribute it
remotely evenly among families
or among individuals, that's
per capita, individual.
And then I said, we've remained a mecca
for immigrants, skilled and unskilled.
So, my view is that globalization
is certainly not harming
the US economy writ broadly.
It is probably contributing
somewhat to the rise
of inequality, and therefore,
it's something that we can deal with
if we deal with our own problems.
I wouldn't wanna be blaming
the Chinese or the Indians.
There's Tom Jefferson
again, and I don't know,
some of you people may
remember the guy over there.
And you might say, what that is,
is a current American student.
If you've read a lot of the reports
about American students not doing well
and da da da da da, turns out,
the most recent look at that
says that American students,
they're not reading Mad
Magazines in their high schools.
They may not be as
intellectual as Tom Jefferson,
but they're doing fine.
At the same point that we've
had this globalization,
labor standards around
the world have gone up.
You've all heard about race to the bottoms
of the globalization, one of my themes
is gonna be globalization is
not the cause of problems.
The cause of problems is
something internal to us
and therefore internal to our politics.
It's how we're dealing
with something that is,
has not affected, yeah, our
GDP growth's been excellent,
it's just who it goes to.
You say, well, there's gonna
be these race to the bottoms,
it turns out, no there isn't.
We've got now, very good evidence,
there were a set of experiments
by one of my colleagues in
the Government Department,
Michael Hiscox, who's been auctioning off
coffee on the web, and
then he's auctioning off
T-shirts on eBay, and he finds,
definitely, people are
willing to pay more money
if you can guarantee something
is made under good conditions.
So he has things made
under good conditions,
and then he removes the
labels on some of it
and sells it without that label,
and you see it's worth about 20, 25% more
people are willing to pay for this.
They're making such good money doing this
that I think his graduate student
may be leaving the university
to sell good products on the web,
set up an internet store.
Similarly, I give the example of Nike,
when they were targeted by activists
and they were very very
rough nasty company
in many ways, they've done
a complete about face,
so now they're very good.
And China's introduced a new labor law.
The only country I know that has reduced
its labor standards
during this period of time
is Australia, and on November,
I think it's 24th or 26th, if
there's some Australians here
you would know the date, John
Howard will be out of office,
precisely because he
introduced a labor law
that reduced the standards
of Australian workers.
And it's the only time I
know where a labor law thing
is turning over a prime minister.
And he's just lost the, whatever it is
that the Australians felt, faith in him.
So this globalization does
not, driving us down and so on.
And we have these two
facts, rising inequality
and we have globalization,
and the globalization,
our income's gone up, it's just gone
to some people and not others,
labor standards, not only in
the US but around the world
have not been driven down by this,
indeed, they're going
up in lots of countries.
Now, what is the question
for the democracy?
And that truly is the
Jeffersonian question for this.
And I put, the challenge,
it's to democracy
and to what I think of
as how well we manage
this 40 to 50 year transition.
40, 50 years, what I say,
what is that number outta your hat?
Change hats for the moment.
But, no it isn't, if it's based,
one, upon very simple modeling
of and the analysis of how
quickly Chinese growth is
and what point they will
reach a level relative to ours
if they keep growing very rapidly,
and India, and then it is based upon
how long it took Japan and
Korea to get up to the level.
Korea was the poorest country in the world
after the Korean War,
they had no resources
and they just hard work and,
and education, really, is what made Korea,
and some US help, but
Korea did a lot of things
on their own, and so the
best you could hope for
in a country that started very poor
is in 40, 50 years they can
get up to the first rank
of places, so this is the
challenge to democracy.
And I'm gonna give you some
evidence in a little of these,
if you're not wealthy, it turns out
people who are not wealthy vote less.
You've got less chance of getting elected,
less chance of having influence,
and that means something,
I gave a talk recently
and some more radicalish person than I,
jumped on me for having
said that US GDP growth
was very good, which it has been.
And then he said, "Well, what
difference does that make?
"Most people haven't had
real income increases,
"or had very small real income increases."
And then, that is the point here.
You got growth of GDP,
which economists like,
the privileges that we should see,
good growth of GDP, that's
what we always look for,
for the papers, and it
can be very different
than growth of citizen wellbeing.
And that's partly the story of the US
over the last, I think, 30 years.
And, I said, in reducing
the scope for government
to operate, and if we go
through this transition period
of adjusting to China and
India catching up with us
in education, catching
up with us in technology,
catching up with us in lots of stuff,
can be a very difficult transition
without, I think, democratic oversight
and I call it the fair
distribution of benefits and costs,
which is important.
I'll talk about the
inequality in politics.
In voting, we've had a generally,
turnout has dropped over time.
It came up a little bit
in the last election,
and hopefully it'll be
higher in the next election.
But, in fact, there was a large drop
in turnout over the period, '64-2000,
and the drop was really big among
less educated people
and lower paid people.
So today, we have a more unevenly,
inequality in voting has increased.
Now here you might say, well,
it's just, it's their choice.
Everyone says the less
educated decided not to vote
and the lower paid decided not to vote.
And what can we do about that?
Well, there are things
we could do about it,
and I think some, many of the states
are trying to do things, I
think it's been a fair effort
by many of our states, but right now,
the voting has shifted from what it was
in the 1960s, so more and
more, disproportionately,
the number of the voters,
tend to be higher educated,
which some of us here might like,
then I just got some counts
on how many millionaires
there were in the Senate and the House.
There were two different counts,
so I don't know if the Senate's 44 or 50.
There's the House, and then
I put in different things,
but it's been worse in US history.
We have a history of our
leaders being way wealthier
than the average citizen.
Abe Lincoln was very
strange in that sense.
And then we've had some
political campaigns,
both by Democrats and Republicans,
remember Mr. Bloomberg who's been on,
who's now an independent,
where Mr. Corzine,
the governor, he was senator now governor
of New Jersey, basically bought
the state of New Jersey election.
And he's a Goldman-Sachs ex-executive,
and he decided he wanted
to become senator.
So, he spent whatever,
60 million, 80 million,
100 million, whatever it
was, and anybody wants
to run against him has got a real problem.
Mr. Kohl is the senator from Wisconsin,
and he says to the voters, "Don't worry,
"I'm so rich I'm not taking any money,
"so I'm gonna do whatever
I want for you people."
And well that's defined.
And Mr. Bloomberg, we know,
spent huge sums of money
and there was one point earlier this year,
some discussion, he
could run for president
because he could just write a check
for one or two billion dollars.
And if you have a one or
two billion dollar campaign,
you would outspend both political parties.
And that's a big thing.
And one of the interesting things
is when people spend, well, in politics,
they spend a lot of time seeking funds,
and we look at the contributions,
it's clear, a lotta rich
people and a lotta companies
regard that as a really good investment.
So there's an economics question,
how come they're not spending more money
on these elections, because, in fact,
the return you get from being close
to the White House when the government
starts giving away contracts and so on,
that really pays off.
So I say, economics are things,
how come the politicians
aren't charging more money,
or the campaigns aren't more expensive
than they would be?
Well, this is an American history,
it's not quite Jefferson's time,
but what the heck, it's
old enough to show,
and this is, you may
not be able to read it,
it says, None but millionaires need apply,
and it's called The Coming
Style of Presidential Election.
And so, all the rich
millionaires are saying,
I wanna run for president,
and of course, if you do
wanna run for president,
and you do not have 100
million or 500 million
or something, gee, you wanna think twice.
You better find someone
with that kind of money,
'cause it is clear that this has become
a very much of a rich person's game.
Now, since the Halloween, I
give you the monster over there,
this is how many lobbyists we have.
K Street, 35,000 registered
lobbyists, et cetera,
and then, the way to understand
how interlinked this is with our politics,
43% of the guys who left Congress,
and I don't have, since,
it says since 1998,
so that's pretty recently,
so probably it's just 2005,
2006 number, they became lobbyists.
So, what you do, is you get into Congress,
you're likely to be a millionaire,
or certainly, you're certainly
dependent on rich folks,
and then when you leave,
you become a lobbyist.
And so, you start thinking, well,
that's the way they think
democracy should be operating,
with these kind of characters?
Now, I've got no strong evidence
that, of course, they're
doing crooked or bad things,
but we, I think we've
heard of some of these guys
in K Street, and we know some
of them have been caught and et cetera.
And then, there's the list of how many
of the former members or heads
of agencies were lobbyists.
American people believe
lobbyists have too much power,
believe it's common for them
to bribe members of Congress.
I don't think that's that frequent
or because, I think it's
been one California guy
and somebody from Ohio have been caught
in real bribe kinds of
stuff, but it's much more
when you get all those huge contributions
to your political campaign
that are presumably legal,
but that clearly affects
your, what you do.
And people can, worried about
corruption in Washington.
So money has clearly played
a substantial role in this.
We then have our own world,
and I don't know what,
how much Berkeley or the
citizens of California,
whether you could change your name,
if some million-billionaire
offered you enough money,
I list here a bunch of foundations,
they were informed, basically
reflect very favorable
to wealthy folks, they're
right, right winged foundations.
I've taken money from Smith
Richardson Foundation,
and I have worked for
the Heritage and the AEI,
so I don't wanna, that may be good
or bad about these foundations,
the Ascherman Professorship,
which is what I hold,
was originally, this
title of the professorship
was for the preservation of capitalism
and defeat of European
social welfare states,
and we had to explain to
the man giving the money
that really the university,
this was not the appropriate
title of the professorship,
and I tried to explain
to the man giving the
money that the one thing
he should absolutely never allow,
do the university to
give this professorship
to an existing professor,
'cause what he wanted
was somebody to do empirical work
but from a fairly
conservative perspective.
And I say, "If they give it to somebody
"on the professorial, we'll
just go off and hire some
"mathematical economist, and
we'll just shift the resources,
"so you can't ever let them give you."
I left for a year and
in that period of time,
the university dean got to have,
and lo and behold, I
was called up and said,
"Oh, you're the professor."
And I said, "But I'm not
what this guy really wants."
He says, "Don't worry, we fooled him."
And now we can appoint
some mathematical economist
who would previously have been the money
that went for my chair.
But point is, this has
been a big movement,
so that when you have wealth,
it doesn't simply buys politicians,
and buys, in a, I don't mean
it in the bribery sense,
it also affects universities.
And it affects think tanks
and it affects professorships,
because they give you lots of money.
So money tends to do that.
Now, we bring the Hamilton Project,
in which the, I
understand, I've worked on,
and I've got a paper, and
I may have a second paper
coming along in the Hamilton Project.
This, I found in checking
Jefferson and Hamilton
on the internet, this popped up.
And this, poor Tom's grave, and supposedly
he's turning over in his grave
on this Hamilton Project.
So, I apologize to him.
And what the Hamilton Project is,
is according to this particular critic,
a thinly veiled pursuit of
moving party policymaking
from the grassroots of
voter primaries and caucuses
to the golden financial
roots of Manhattan.
Meaning, the Hamilton Project is funded
by Wall Street money,
which I believe it is,
and it is an effort of,
basically conservative Democratic groups
to influence politics
and political outcomes
in the directions that they would like,
and I think it is correct
that the naming it after Hamilton,
I said, "Gee, is he a great
icon of the Democratic party?"
The history is, of course, he was not,
he was the opposition
to the Democratic party.
He was the Federalist party.
And this particular gentleman
who was a very distinguished
analyst of US politics, Kevin Phillips,
just thought this was awful.
So I apologized to Tom
Jefferson for doing,
for the paper that he was referring to,
but to be clear, it was a paper
for redistribution of
income to graduate students
and not towards the money elite.
And I took a lot of flak from
the Hamilton Project people
as to why we just
shouldn't hire immigrants
to do the science and engineering,
why should Americans be
doing this, this work?
And I thought, maybe in
the back of their heads
is they want all the bright Americans
to get in work for Wall Street firms,
they don't want any
competition offered to them,
I don't know, so that's the, this thing.
And then I just think
of, if it's the level
of the way in which money can
incredibly affect policies.
I had this nightmare.
Oh, I suppose I shoulda
just put some cartoon,
some Halloween things there.
Think Bill Gates, he's done wonderful.
I think he's, the Gates
Foundation is just wonderful,
they're spending money probably
faster than they should,
but they have to under tax laws,
they're doing great things,
but just imagine if he had different view.
If he took 40 billion dollars
to fund policy and research
focused on preserving wealth?
He could've, there's no
question, he could've done that.
Via control of the media, he coulda said,
Rupert Murdoch, you're a left wing creep.
I'm gonna buy CBS and NBC.
And I'm gonna have, really show people
what they should think.
He could've set up a
university that would destroy
Harvard and Berkeley, Gates University.
He would've offered every professor
half a million dollars, and
we'd all be gone, out the door,
and et cetera, and this
could've incredibly affected,
their level of power that
exists with the moneys
is just, to me, remarkable,
intellectual debate and policy.
Thank goodness, he has not done that,
and he has done, his
foundation does not do that,
but that's certainly a danger we would've,
that would exist, and
some next billionaire,
who knows what the next multi billionaire
will decide to do with their money?
I should say, just make one comment,
about the American multi-billionaires,
when I was in Australia,
excuse me, Argentina,
Argentina's doing very badly, and I said,
"Where is the Ross Perot of Argentina?
"Where is the businessman who thinks
"he can save the country?"
And in Argentina, they looked at me
and they said, "In Argentina,
you don't use money
"to get politics, as you do in the US.
"In Argentina, you get into
politics to make money."
And that's a different thing.
And then I give a
statement that shocked me,
'cause I was telling one of my friends
I was giving this talk here, and I said,
"Hey, what do you think about da da da,"
and he first said, "Oh, you've gotta quote
"Jean Jacques Rousseau."
And I said, "Does Jefferson
know very much about Rousseau?"
And he said, "Well, Jefferson,
needed to read French."
It turns out, Jefferson did not think
all that much of
Rousseau, but nonetheless,
this is a statement
about how money gets in,
and then the stunning thing
is they pay mercenary troops,
and then at the bottom,
this friend of mine said,
"Do you know there's
more private contractors
"in Iraq than US military personnel?"
I said, "That can't possibly be true."
And so he sent me the site,
I give the site to you,
and then you get the numbers.
The contractors, by the
way, were all being paid
out of taxpayer money, these
are the Blackstone guys
and the independents, and boy,
that's mercenary troops, more mercenaries
than American soldiers, and
they cost us more money,
as far as what one can see.
So you just sorta sit
there and you just wonder,
I will put down money
that we will find out
that the Blackstone
guys and a lot of these
private contractors
made large contributions
to the political parties, probably more
to the Republicans, and this is the US
having a mercenary army out there,
which fits with the Rousseau stuff.
That's bad, okay, so I
think there is a challenge
in the politics to this.
I imagine you know, it occurs,
you have young Abe Lincoln
there, and he's saying, Dad or mom,
can I run for president?
And what advice would you
give young Abe Lincoln?
I would say, go to Wall Street,
get yourself a partnership
in Goldman-Sachs.
Make a few billion, and then, yes, son.
Anyone can run for president,
as long as they have that kind of money.
And then I would say,
of course, you could,
if you wanted to, go around
and spend all your time
as a politician, getting
money from the wealthy folks
and that really drives
some politicians mad
that they spend all their time doing that.
So it has to be corroding our democracy.
Okay, so now I'm gonna
give you some solutions.
I called it first The Jefferson Way.
Jefferson was a big states rights guy,
and he was against the
national government.
Hamilton was for national government.
I've been working on some
things with some colleagues,
something we call progressive federalism,
which is very much states' rights,
and see, then I will talk
about the other things,
the shared capitalism, so
these are my solutions,
if I can phrase it
right to this challenge.
Oh, and then I pointed out, I
didn't bring that hat with me.
He was a member of the
secret club called Flat Hat.
I do have a Flat Hat, but
I just didn't carry it
with me on the airplane.
'Kay, what do I mean by states rights?
You don't normally think of as a solution
to inequality problems
or things like that,
globalization, and so I'll give you
what I think are the
positive things about this.
Most social services are state,
there's a lot of diversity,
and I think it is great
that California has chosen
some energy policies
that the state of
Arkansas does not choose.
We don't wanna be locked
in, everybody's gotta do
exactly the same thing,
the states have done well
at delivering services, experimentation,
and then the fifth one
is something I don't know
of any real evidence for,
but it's an interesting proposition,
'cause you notice that Republican
governors and legislatures
in states often make what seem to be
more rational decisions,
thoughtful decisions,
than the administration in Washington.
And you sorta sit there
and say, well, why is that?
Well, I think ideology
gets lost a little bit
when you're dealing with real
problems at a state level.
Whereas in Washington, you can
have ideology running wild,
but I have no real evidence for that.
This is just a listing of states
that have enacted progressive
laws as of March 2007.
So states rights as a
vehicle for preserving
Democratic things,
minimum wage laws we know,
they've been widely studied, indeed,
that's been the heart
of our great increase
in knowledge that minimum wage laws
don't have much effect on employment,
and that's because states have this right.
But state supplements the federal EITC,
renewable energy, you go
down the list of legislation
and of things, and the
governor of California
has been very good at this, of course,
pushing with world leaders
for energy and energy things,
and in my state before he, Mr. Romney,
who has a medical, or with
the Democratic legislature
passed the medical plan, which he now,
I think, thinks is socialistic and evil
and he was never really in the state,
and it wasn't him who
signed the bill and so on,
but notice these are, we
have much bigger set of this,
and it just lists the states
that have done things.
Now the interesting is what
the national response to this is.
And the, limiting the healthcare program,
okay, they don't want to
pass anymore spending on it,
but they're also using as
many administered rules
as they can to limit healthcare.
So we do know that in
one sense, the states
are actually a bulwark for democracy
against, would have been
a federal government
that has not been good.
And then, these are just
remarkable, I think.
The key doctrine that the
federal government uses
to limit state democracy,
and therefore, I think,
to limit all of our democracy
is federal preemption.
Federal preemption means
that you can't do anything
once the federal government
has stepped into an area.
And what we've seen in
the last several years,
it's come to an end, 2000,
with the change in election,
the Democratics winning,
we've seen that Republicans
who supposedly are
devoted to, conservatives
who are supposedly
devoted to states rights
doing everything they can to
remove the rights of states,
to make decisions that run counter
to their particular views, which,
Democrats have done this too, so I,
but right now it's Republicans doing it.
So I give you energy
policy, they wanna make sure
that any private utility
that has a federal permit
can seize any land they want,
and no state can stop them.
The Class Action Fairness,
and there's the statement
from the National Conference
of State Legislatures,
undermines our system of federalism
and disrespects our
state courts, et cetera.
Then, the one that was the scariest to me,
is the Law Enforcement Safety,
I didn't know this was passed.
Does anyone here got a gun?
Carrying a concealed weapon?
You do have a right to
carry a concealed weapon,
and the state of California
cannot stop anyone
if they are a current,
off-duty, or retired
law enforcement agent.
This was a special federal
law designed to stop states
from not allowing people
to carry concealed weapons.
That just, you know.
And then we have a statement
for the International
Association of Chiefs of Police,
that the police want this, of course not.
They don't want random people,
even ex-police officers, carrying guns.
The reason this cuts to me, was in a class
at Harvard many years ago, we did have
a policeman from Texas who
came to the class with his gun.
And so we said to him,
"Sir, we don't allow,"
"I don't know if Harvard has a rule,
"but I assume we have
a rule, we don't allow
"people to bring guns to our classes."
And he said, "But what happens
"if there's some bad guys here?
"I gotta do that then."
(audience laughs)
And I explained to him
that maybe we could tackle
the bad guy or something.
(audience laughs)
And he put his gun away, but I realize now
if someone came to the thing,
and this was a police officer,
he was, you know, you couldn't stop him.
You couldn't legally say,
No, that's not allowed.
It is remarkable.
This is removal of states' rights,
states' rights as a thing.
So, I think one of the things, and I hope
the next presidency, whichever,
Democrat or Republican,
has greater respect for states' rights,
where we still have some democratic,
where we have some democratic procedures.
Second thing that I offered
as a solution to this,
was, I call it shared capitalism.
And this is very simple, if capital
is gonna be in the driver's seat
for this 40 or 50 year transition,
we'll wanna make sure we're capitalists.
Let's make sure we have some money.
Turns out, we paid for some questions
on this general social
survey every couple of years.
Almost half of private sector workers
actually are paid in some way
that you would consider
to be capital related.
So, hey, they're covered
by profit sharing,
gain sharing, they own university stock,
and they hold company stock options.
I took this fact to the Harvard,
and I said, "I wanna be paid a share
"of the Harvard Fund, Harvard Endowment,"
which does extremely well as you may know.
The university refused to
change my pay to this way.
While I explained to them
how it actually increased
the devotion to the employer,
and I would work harder and so on.
So we have moved into this.
And somewhere on the order of 35%, 40%
of the stock market are owned
by pension funds, workers.
And so, this is going on in a lot of,
and that means we will benefit,
even though we may not
benefit in our wages,
if profits go up, we benefit as profit,
and I think that's positive.
The internet, I don't know too much about,
but I gather that if we can
have a good YouTube movie
showing you combing your
hair for half an hour,
you're gonna lose a lot
of support from people
who wonder about you,
so, and that does offer,
I think, average citizens
a way of combating money
because you couldn't get as many people
tapping into YouTube, with
whatever advertisements you do,
I hope that's the case.
The last thing is the
more, is the globalization.
How do we deal with footloose
capital and things like that?
Turns out, there's a lot of
local bias in the economy.
People do spend in their local area,
firms prefer to have
products, intermediate goods,
that's where there's a lot, I and S means
investment savings are highly
correlated across countries.
There's no evidence that
that has weakened over time,
even with globalization, people are,
I can offer some of the people here
would you like to come to
teach in, I don't know,
Little Rock University, how much more
would I have to pay you to leave Berkeley?
If you're a grad student, how
much would I have to pay you
to go to, I don't know,
some small university
and get your degree in Mississippi
or Idaho, I mean, what the heck,
I don't wanna be discriminatory
against the South.
And, yeah, people are willing
to take differentials,
they're willing to pay more rent
to live in certain places, so it is clear
there are local things that matter a lot,
and then I just have these two questions,
I'm not sure what the answer is,
because we would like to
keep the country ahead
during this transition, as the technology
and education is growing up elsewhere,
we don't wanna take big losses.
But to our people, so we'd
like to be able to say
we can do some good things here
and that'll keep some good industries
and good jobs here, and I just don't know,
how, we don't have good evidence
on how much we can do with that.
And then I said, well,
there are these dangers.
I won't ask you to
identify the two people,
except neither of them is President Bush
nor Dick Cheney dressed up for Halloween.
We can have all these
disasters in this period,
and then I do have a
statement for you here,
this does come from the administration,
that I'm obviously very dubious about,
and they're still looking for the WMDs,
and then, I wonder what Rumney found.
Oh my god, so we now
know where the WMDs are,
and who the enemy of
the country really is.
But I think, let me phrase it this way,
'cause I'm no Greek, I mean,
the administration is what it is,
and it is though, through
education, research
and things like that that
we're gonna cure our problems,
not through other strange things.
So I am a very positive person at the end,
I say, "Well, I think we
can overcome this challenge
"to our democracy, part of
it is that the millionaires
"and billionaires are not evil people,
"there's a lot more cooperation
"than we anticipate from economic models."
We now have brain scans that show
this, it's hard wired fairness into us,
so as people, I don't think we're,
we're not there to be totally bad,
and I loved it when Warren Buffett
said he should pay higher taxes,
and he thought all the corporations
should pay higher taxes,
all the rich people
and then one of my friends
said, "Can't he wait till I
make my 40 billion dollars,
"and then pay the taxes?"
And it is true, that Mr. Buffett
for all his being a great millionaire,
he didn't say these things
while he was making his money.
He waited till retirement.
That also says maybe that's
people should respect elders,
that they have a different perspective.
Okay, this was brought to
you by the Hat Company,
and then, for Halloween,
I had some assistants,
and this is a great movie,
if you've never seen it,
Vincent Price, that's the Halloween stuff.
Okay, I'm done.
(audience applauds)
(soft music)